Do you recommend filtering city tap water? Absolutely positively. You do not want fluoride, you don't want chlorine.
Two poisons fluoride is just criminal that they're still put into the water system.
You definitely have to get that out. You do not want to be drinking that.
What filter do you recommend? You can use reverse osmosis. You can use a burky filter.
Typically, a simple carbon filter will take out the fluoride and chlorine, but a carbon filter will take out heavy metals.
If you have heavy metals in the water, that's where you have to use reverse osmosis.
Some people say, well, reverse osmosis causes dead water. It doesn't have any minerals in it.
You know, but you're not drinking your water for your minerals in the minerals that you do get in your water are earth-bound milling minerals.
They're not the type of minerals that are good for you anyhow.
So that whole argument just does not hold water.
Our water would come from Atlanta to get out.
I would recommend reverse osmosis. We have reverse osmosis here at the office.
Even though we have well water at the office, the chest is higher than nitrates.
Nitrates, so we have a reverse osmosis here.
Our water at our home is well water and we tested it and it's good.
So we do that on cloud development. It's not true. We should do that.